[Música]
hoje eu vou colocar pra vocês
há uma trajetória de vida aqui jogo da
vida e começa sempre tenho a minha
infância 17 anos de idade comecei a
trabalhar no céu com ajudei a criar em
são josé do rio preto tinha o clube essa
informação da escola de saúde pública da
região que puder trabalho e renda para
quem pudesse está estudando a por meio
do conhecimento da ciência a fora de são
josé do rio preto como foi o meu caso a
com isso a gente tinha 11 muito grande
que era com você atingir essa escola de
química e científico porque a escola de
química na hora tinha que ter uma outra
escola e por meio da ciência a gente
conseguir trabalho e renda
tá se empreender e fui descobrindo eu
gosto muito interessante
ninguém acredita no seu empreendimento
poderia inovador baseado num obstáculo
seria desviar
geralmente você mesmo que banca esse
empreendimento
as instituições financeiras isso eu fui
descobrir já no terceiro ano da escola
de química teve que fazer um estágio são
paulo depois toda brasília
fui fazer matemática e física e tive que
terminar em dois anos
primeiro não era o possível terminar em
dois filmes e convenceu o ministro da
educação a fazer com que isso ocorresse
em dois anos dois cursos de matemática e
física com uma média acumulada de 4.705
eu tinha que ser alguma coisa
diferenciada para que as pessoas
pudessem investir naquilo que eu
gostaria de renovar uma forma de você
conseguir recursos e inovação é você tem
imagem a imagem de uma pessoa nova de 20
anos pode contar com ela mesmo não é
então o exemplo que você tem que dar a
imagem é você mesmo e com isso foi a
minha vida toda até hoje
durante esse processo eu me tornei
foi fazer mestrado em informática para
internet porque a matemática diz que é
transdisciplinar e com isso eu fui pra
público do rio de janeiro participei do
primeiro programa de mestrado em
informática no país e onde fui estudar a
informática aplicada para a ciência e
tecnologia e não informática aplicada à
administração para mim eletrônico
especificamente para a computação mas
para as áreas onde tinha problema
reconhecimento de câncer taxonomia de
plantas mas por meio de pesquisa
desenvolvimento e ser um diferencial
se você fosse um cd pesquisa você não ia
achar então com o meu processo inovador
é investir o meu mestrado na ciência e
tecnologia em setores que tinha
problemas que não foram resolvidos bom
com isso eu terminei a minha graduação
foi fazer foi trabalhado embrapa 7588 e
até 78 e depois de trabalhar eu fui
ganho a uma bolsa de estudos por
exterior
aí eu fui trabalhar um pouquinho do meu
conhecimento para a transição finalidade
na trânsito na verdade eu conseguir que
existe um programa de doutorado veja bem
na cidade americana que só tinha
problema disciplinar
e esse programa disciplinar que existia
ele não deixava você fazer uma proposta
de uma tese que não gosto daquela área
o mundo inteiro assim berklee qualquer
lugar na europa na ásia no brasil todo
lugar
então minha proposta como era área de
administração de negócios de custo e
desperdício trabalhar com gente e
trabalhar com o software que não é
programa de computador usado em todo
mundo pensa que só ser um programa de
computador não é um problema só estação
todos os elementos um programa de
computador deve te nesses três vezes
sujeitos todos eles o prêmio nobel todos
eles eram muito importantes né
na química
é muito importante na economia e geram
muita importância a matemática não sei
se ouvir falar de joão méxico por
exemplo a pessoa contribuiu com a gente
ele era um matemático que trabalhava com
jogos ganha ganha
a teoria do equilíbrio a gente precisa
disso e é porque o que queria de
equilíbrios e só no equilíbrio quando
você sente que você não está mais no
equilíbrio a a partir desse momento em
que a gente começa a ter essa é esse
desafio eu não tava sozinho estava com
dois mil e 500 pessoas as mais notáveis
do mundo na área de chamada engenharia
de software e que não era um programa de
computador um fazia uma especificação o
outro fazia o desenho como se fosse um
projeto do engenheiro outro fazia o
programa de computador fato
implementaram outros testava nem tudo
uma mesma pessoa fazia tudo aquilo de
que ficar bem claro pra passar próximo o
que tinha fica bem claro o resultado que
tinha todo o resultado que ele tinha ele
passava o resultado pra frente
esse resultado era então no final a
engenharia de software que ele estava
fazendo pagar das estrelas
eu já tinha que funcionar com o soldado
no avião em todos os lugares onde
existia os disparos que eram necessários
e eram ordenados pelo comando do estado
mas essa foi uma experiência muito
grande e inter relacionamento pessoal
foi fortíssimo que tive que lidar com
militares civil tive de lidar com gente
muito pobre rica tinha que funcionar com
acadêmicos tive que operacionaliza quase
todo tipo de gente e é onde assustador
né
aquele menino desde o começo sabia de
nada até hoje não sei ficar alisando com
pessoas de perfis totalmente diferente é
bom a a apartir do momento em que a
gente à volta dessas linhas de 1984 eu
volto pra cá eu vou trabalhar na embrapa
embrapa empresa brasileira de pesquisa
agropecuária onde eu falei para vocês
que eu fui trabalhar com o táxi de
planta no começo quando saí do mestrado
em informática e me tornei diretor
executivo da embrapa
porque eu me tornei diretor executivo da
europa e eu embora do brasil um ano
antes
o collor assumiu eu não gostava da
escola eu embora eu e vivendo sozinhas
de repente o convidado para ser diretor
executivo da embrapa junto com o
presidente e eu fui e assumiu o então
diretor executivo da embrapa o que era
um requisito era embrapa fosse
reengenharia da embrapa tinha cinco mil
projetos de pesquisa e no fim fizemos e
50 projetos prioritários trabalho
regeria fantástico foi o que fiz não por
50 os líderes de pesquisas embrapa todo
o pensador lembrar pra não tinha
computador pra que ele sofre tudo que
era feita pelo pesquisador era
processado estatisticamente
economicamente pela sede da embrapa
levava 23 meses para ter o resultado da
pesquisa com o pesquisador precisava
daquele tempo real
transformou se transformando em uma rede
de pesquisadores
recusando a repartição onde cada um
deles iria está fazendo o em rede o
trabalho de pesquisa dele isso foi uma
coisa que ficou para a cultura da
empresa até hoje é assim né
então dentro dessa característica
existiu também um negócio muito
importante que é o seguinte tinha perda
de alimentos em toda a estrada do brasil
em reduzir a perda de alimentos
tudo isso aprendi na guerra das estrelas
utilizando aquela tecnologia quem
desenvolveu essa tecnologia e usei pra
dentro da embrapa para fora da entrada e
por isso este foi reduzindo os
desperdícios que jeito projetos um
projeto chamado segurança alimentar
fizemos uma conferência internacional a
integração dos sistemas e chamamos todas
as cadeias produtivas de todas as áreas
religiões se possa imaginar favelas a
isso no parlamento latino-americano em
1994 e com isso a gente conseguiu a
desenvolver o instituto internacional de
integração de sistemas que integram a
cadeias produtivas no brasil a essa
história que estou contando pra vocês
a precisão no começo não sei se lembra
do banco do milênio aquele problema da
tata que todas as instituições que
cuidam da defesa americana ela precisava
de tirar essas datas dos programas
estratégicos ela dava muito receio que o
mundo inteiro está com certo receio
o que ocorreu a gente desenvolveu é por
meio dessa tecnologia a resolução do be
do minério não só eu mas uma equipe né
e essa equipe era a equipe daqui do
brasil e de fora sempre contando com uma
rede internacional lembra daqueles dois
mil e 500 pesquisadores direito software
sempre tiveram presença da minha vida um
segredo nunca disconnect da sua própria
rede
é muito importante a outra parte muito
importante que teve foi o seguinte que
todas as empresas no brasil seja a caixa
econômica federal se lembrava seja qual
o multinacional ibm quem é ela não tem
um problema chamado de
interoperabilidade e essa
interoperabilidade como elas se
comunicam entre si e não é por meio de
ferramentas e nem por meio do computador
permite resultados
eu falo com você como eu vou falar com
vocês
mostrando que tem o resultado por
exemplo
levante a mão aqui quem tem um obstáculo
na vida olha só o levante agora quem tem
uma uma patinadora passar por esse
obstáculo mas ninguém
nós temos que trabalhar bastante toda a
transformação social começa aí certo
então assim que eu tive que começar
nesse programa
como é que eu vou convencer as empresas
falarem umas com as outras
como é que uma empresa para qual outro
por meio de resultados aí formamos então
redes e tecnologia para que isso pudesse
ocorrer
fizemos uma proposta pelo ministério do
planejamento a caixa econômica federal
participou banco do brasil participou e
dentro disso fizemos essa parceria com a
puc do rio de janeiro a puc paraná a
universidade de brasília e fizemos
alguns casos só que era difícil testar
aí entra o processo de que a gente chama
de contribuição social a verdade é que
sempre a gente sempre
era o meu é meu trabalho o qual era a
minha tentativa de dar uma contribuição
social
com isso daí a gente chegou em
experimentação em grande massa e com
isso a gente foi mostrando como agente
opa desculpe como agente a mostrava a
através de de conferências e fizemos a
primeira conferência a que foi a
conferência da asps 2013 e dentro dessa
conferência depois nós fomos para o
trabalho de cidades inteligentes tudo
aquilo que nós aplicamos na caixa na
embrapa em todos os lugares
aplicamos das cidades inteligentes em
hortolândia e agora estamos isso maré
fazendo alguma coisa interessante que
entre na atualização da rede top 3 e com
isso a gente vai estar trabalhando nessa
rede onde você tem o autoconhecimento
ela promove que você mesmo se auto
capacita alto aprende e você mesmo
coloca seu conhecimento e compartilha
uma rede geral essa rede geral é uma
rede mundial que está no brasil agora e
vamos estar colocando agora o exterior
fazendo com que as injustiças pode
colaborar uma com a outra
um case faz se um queijo na área de
saúde e na área de educação
essa tecnologia que a gente veio
contribuir é uma tecnologia única no
mundo
participam o mundo inteiro não é só
brasileiro tem nada a ver comigo eu sou
simplesmente um participante
sou quem coordena essa área essa
propriedade intelectual é minha mas na
verdade eu compartilho sua propriedade
intelectual com o mundo todo os meus
gros raymond e ramazotti teve algumas
pessoas muito importantes que participar
de tudo isso eu acho que é importante
ser colocada
o ala anthony que já tinha morrido olha
os cejas participou durante o processo
emperra marujo que já tinha aparecido
aqui conhecer números primos essa é uma
pessoa interessante de tempo dá pra
colocar ele nunca estudou uma foi a
pessoa que mais colaborou com a teoria
dos números primos na matemática no piso
e foi uma pessoa premiada pela escola
inglesa
uma outra pessoa foi nesh que eu
gostaria de deixar uma mensagem muito
forte
a mensagem que perguntar para ele com a
equação que você fez pra fazer o jogo
ganhou a escola ea equação do amor
foi isso que ele colocou isso que eu
deixo com vocês a e essa minha história
que vai até 2019 é de 2009 em diante mas
dez anos a gente vai estar promovendo
esse compartilhamento do
autoconhecimento com toda essa rede do
mundo inteiro vai participar mais de mil
instituições convido todos vocês a
poderem participar era isso que eu tinha
a dizer pra vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]